i don't remember this at all we're
calling this the one where courtney
doesn't remember playing monica
cox landed the role that changed her
life
on the show that would become one of the
most popular in the history of
television i see it on tv sometimes
tonight right i stop and go
oh my god i don't remember this at all
that is so funny is that right yeah it
doesn't matter what generation is
watching it it's just it holds up people
can relate to every character i don't
care how big the cell phone is the
computer you can't lift
life is that way and you know if you
have a friend group which is your family
yeah the actress made the confession
during a sit down for sunday today
i just remember it being such an amazing
time but it doesn't come as that big of
a surprise check out this et chat from
2016 where courts struggle to remember
major plot points
when you look back at monica gellar and
phoebe buffet where do each of you think
that each other's character is today
what are they up to
i haven't thought about that at all
i don't know well i mean phoebe married
a
like connecticut guy right or they were
like a
upper east side new york family marion
mike yeah yeah courtney forgot about
paul rudd despite playing a bridesmaid
in the very memorable snow day wedding
we were married to mike yep she married
mike okay who played mike paul right
that's mike oh my god of course sorry
you got married to him yeah was there a
wedding there was a wedding i didn't was
i there i don't remember you were there
it was in the snow
i okay honestly you don't know yeah
remember you guys got married outside of
central perk in the snow
i don't remember that okay
well
i got married
could someone get me a code i'm freaking
phrasing
she also has no recollection of what her
tv husband's job was
what was chandler
oh we didn't know what he did did we
ever find out what he did with his job
but we'll give her that one like lisa
mentioned even the characters never
really knew what is chandler bing's job
oh gosh this has something to do with
numbers and processing well it carries a
briefcase ten seconds you need this or
you lose the game it's um it has
something to do with transponding oh oh
he's a transparent insurance monster
that's not even a
word it does seem some memories came
flooding back during the cast reunion
last year though memories just flashback
of like jokes coming out of the bathroom
no do not
just like stupid things that you would
do
it was the most emotion i i i had slept
so well the night before
woke up i wasn't nervous at all just
feeling good the first question like how
do you feel i was like
and then started crying and then i
walked on the set and i had no idea
that seeing everything look exactly the
same and these incredible friends that
even though i see
these two a lot
i i still was just like
jennifer you kind of looked at me and
she's like
it was just the most emotional thing and
then today she can't stop crying so
[Music]